Matt here with code tagging tutorials
just wanted to talk a little bit about
developing game engines and making
decisions behind the scene this is not a
how-to video it's more of just some
observations and some thoughts so okay
so let's jump into it I'm here kind of
working on some structure for my new
game still pretty early on in the
development and one thing I noticed is
you know a lot of this stuff I've
somewhat pseudo implemented somewhere
before in one of my previous projects so
a lot of times I'll just be like okay
well rather than spend a bunch of time
rewriting this let's just pull in what
we currently have and we'll adapt as
necessary and one of the things that
tends to happen when I'm doing these
sort of things is I begin to recognize
things I could have done better like for
instance what we have here is a camera
class we're looking at and it's a pretty
standard camera class notably this is uh
not included right now so that's
something we have to decide
um a little off topic but what unique
instance does here is basically is it
gives the class an ID type setup so you
can do a git ID and anytime you
instantiate one it gets a unique ID some
special stuff like that um
which is you know if you want to see
more on that let me know I can make a
video on that now the camera let's talk
about the camera because that's uh where
I noticed this thing so the camera also
has a Skybox when I was designing this
camera in the Skybox I had to figure out
a way to tie them together because
essentially the Skybox it needs to know
for its rendering purposes what the
current uh all the stuff basically the
viewport
your view Matrix and your projection
Matrix those are the main things the
Skybox needs to know about so
in your your Sky boxes also it tends to
be tied to a particular camera like a
certain camera just always sees the sky
box and that's how it renders so I
thought it would be a great idea to just
make a unique pointer to the sky box and
just create the the Skybox just on the
stack here anytime you make a camera you
can also make a sky box or you can leave
it null which you know is fine really
that's the way I had it designed that's
the way it worked in the old Archer
engine but you know I was thinking what
about if the Skybox could also just only
take any what it needs and just not be
here at all we could do all the Skybox
on its own in its own area not tied in
with the camera and then what would the
Sky Box need it would need things that
needs to render it needs a viewport The
View Matrix and I don't know I might
need some other of these things I think
it needs field of view maybe viewport
view Matrix field of view just a few
specific things for it to render it
doesn't need all this camera stuff is
the point so a lot of this stuff is uh a
bit Overkill so what we could do is we
could uh take this Sky Box here
and go to where it's set up here so what
we could do here is well anyway
instantiate the Skybox you know normally
we take the files that it brings in
which is kind of a slow method another
thing that needs to be Factor but we
could also say
um well we need a camera reference we
could just reference a camera but then
we start getting into more interesting
things like when the camera changes it
needs to update the Skybox so we could
do a reference in each class to each
other and kind of tie them together but
that feels a little bit too attached so
we could do that though that is an
option we could do we could make a
camera pointer
and
being that it's a camera pointer we can
say that it's not a charge of the memory
it uh you know relies on the other
camera to stay instantiated there's some
requirements that pop up with that so
you can do it it's not too bad but once
again the camera just has a ton of
information that the Skybox doesn't care
about Skybox only really cares about
those view projection matrices that we
were looking at I think it's mainly The
View Matrix and projection Matrix that
get updated on the shaders but if the
field of view changes or if the viewport
changes or in other words the screen
size most of the time but it could be
just some other
picture-in-picture type set up within
your screen if any of those change on
this Skybox we want to update on the dry
box as well so not just find its screen
so we have to think of that now because
if we don't have the Skybox here and we
implement it separately and then give it
a camera and what if the camera stuff
changes well we do have access to the
camera so we could just check it here
directly on the sky box but where at
there's no update method or anything
like that so maybe we would have to put
in an update method and on the update we
would check whether the camera any of
those changed on the camera or not and
if they did then we we'd uh push some
updates to whatever's rendering our
Skybox you know to the uniforms and
that's another set of complications
there's always a set of complications so
we had to just kind of keep asking what
other designs could we come up with that
might be better because both of those
both those previous methods the ones
I've talked about in this video both
worked there's not anything particularly
wrong with him other than the thing that
might be wrong with him is that they're
not necessarily the best choice but they
will get you going you can just
implement it that way and now that's
kind of what this video is about is just
looking at old implementations and
realizing just through studying and
practicing and keeping up with things
and by exposing yourself to New Concepts
even if it's just you know like my
design pattern videos that's kind of the
point just expose you to New Concepts it
might not all click in the moment but if
you if you go through all those you will
come out the other side after you know
maybe you have a day or two off you a
weekend or whatever you come back and
just notice things that you didn't
notice before and
that's uh I find that to be just one of
the coolest things about programming and
just continuing to try to push yourself
and learn and uh
yeah just thought I'd share that with
you guys so I guess for me going forward
here you know I basically got to decide
at this point what to do with the Skybox
and camera and I think I've figured out
what I want to do and yeah I'm going to
remove it from the camera I'm gonna have
it be its own Standalone object but I
think we want to just pull from a camera
a viewport view Matrix
and projection Matrix but the thing is
here we don't want to do it every frame
we don't want to be pulling all the time
because the majority of the time
the viewport's just going to be sitting
there because you know a lot of times in
a game or whatever you're just sitting
there looking at the same thing or
messing with inventory or who knows what
you're not always moving these matrices
around and you're not always changing
your view so you don't want to pull when
you don't have to so what's a better
method I might just keep this Skybox
reference here but rather than unique
I'll either make it shared or I'll just
make it a raw pointer
and anytime any of these change we'll
call a method that we're going to add to
the Sky Box called like update or
something
um Boyd update matrices or something
like that
and with that sort of set up we can just
pass in
the matrices or
do we want to pass them in we could do
them by const reference so it'd be kind
of fast but that still does use up some
some caching uh but not too much
um
and then we'd have to add a few more
things to the Sky Box here to uh make it
update its proper Shader because I
believe it's all done internally
somewhere else so there's yet another
thing to think about and that's this is
kind of in a nutshell what happens when
you develop a game engine you just run
into a lot of things like this you know
actually you don't really run into this
tilt after you get through all your
setup you know once you start actually
having things working and then realize
oh I need to I need to slot this in
somewhere or I need to change
something else to make it fit better
that's when you realize things might not
be organized as well as you originally
thought but uh all right well hope you
enjoyed these these thoughts and this
analysis and just uh I feel like this is
uh something that some people might
enjoy or have uh
further Insight on or anything like that
so anyway I'll see you guys next time
peace out
consider becoming a patron today and
you'll get access to some extra content
the Discord I will answer any questions
you have and you'll become uh joined
into the the coffee talk where we talk
about I don't know what we talk about I
guess I just I just talked to you guys
have you seen my Brett stapler